[Applauso]
[Musica]
ciao a tutti oggi il nuovo gialle su
completare grande spiazzo visto che mi è
astenuto abolizione di suscitare
soprattutto quelli super fortunato e io
vendo quasi sempre quindi mediante anche
questa volta vincente uno svizzero io
allora channing che mi avete richiesto e
che è molto popolare in america dello
stesso buzzanca che chiamare la sorella
piccolini super carlini che facevano
questo challenge di grafica noi abbiamo
bari quanti rifiniti ingredienti slide e
altre conto insomma e andremo a tirare
la corda e abbiamo messo peggio faccia
volta potere il fidato aver la meglio e
abbiamo problemi di spazio poche parole
fiume non vi preoccupate non riuscite a
leggere bene comunque emozionare svuota
e basta quello di scegliere una nota
andremo a mettere i vari ingredienti e
fuori
a chi riesce lo sarai molto bello se a
me o capitale sempre poi alla fine del
video dovrete buttare lo slang e bello
sia per aspetto sia territori a smr
quindi mi raccomando tenetevi pronti
in più c'è un'altra cosa e questa volta
in questa volta ampio queste capita la
tabella scambio con saturate leggere
ogni volta che capita quella azzurra
scambio dovremmo scambiare le slime
quindi è stato fortunato ho avuto gli
ingredienti migliori sei capitato nella
scambio io prenderò il tutto la lingua
vecchia basta sarò la prima mai spiegate
quelli brutti
la casella stop che vuol dire che lui
comprenderle su un guanto non puoi
aggiungere nessun ingrediente che
significa di girare una turchia e
un'altra volta quindi siete pronti a
fare deve pronti come sempre lasciato in
bella se volete facciamo altri challenge
assieme a una bretella che vi ho
aggiunto e se di tui quindi possiamo
scegliere noi quali green che una volta
cosa casella perché tipo la casella
joslyn
siete pronti l'ora di iniziare la sua
bellezza vedere se volete vedere altre
sale d'azione socialisti sicuri nei
commenti no penso che bush non quello
che avevo dubbi anche in questo sito
trasparente che viva ecco qua in quanto
trasparente che ovviamente entrò alla
colla trasparente ora andiamo a metterla
nella sosta la massima di vertenza da
fare perché si tagliano le dita
[Musica]
pressione che siete tutte le dita per
date come col nuovo destro pubblico la
forbice si sta cercando stato ma la
destra sentiamo fontana tutto tre
mostrano in porcata scopo che magari
stai attento a dobbiamo capirlo
la trasparente pressi della catena di
cambio o finti posso credere quale
autorità fortuna io non ho niente donne
nella mia cosa trasparente indovinabili
scelto di mettere da parte la scambio
[Musica]
sono stato interrotto no io molto verde
a volta pensando non sarà così sfigata
visto che a me non piace perdere il
claim il più sembra farina ammuffita no
certo deve capitare proprio a me vedo
veramente la maledizione degli eventi o
dentro messo farina farina di mais e poi
ho messo dei clipper berghi il risultato
eternit in franca sembra farina ha una
vita guardate qua
[Musica]
diventate teniamo stretto tutto questo è
veramente una volta mi ha capito un po
[Musica]
bravi per soldi racconta tutto ha
scritto perché si chiama rimuovere delle
dita da quelle che la polpastrello viene
tagliato alla fidapa s
solo chi casino per niente dai che ti
amo questi ma certo
posso immaginare come sarà questo tavolo
con un finto tutto tra il corso che
sfrutta le guardate che stima in verde
posso
[Musica]
no deve ritirare
tutto a fare uno scambio se lo prende
niente cambio scambio stato capito bene
io però spiegano cerone la condizione
non ti devi toccarti battuto siccome
pende l'abbiamo un contatto devono
ritirare speriamo bene
[Musica]
sul tappeto verde formalmente perché
questa bene ho tirato quattro modi più
di te il 3 monteferri voga niente
fantastico pare proprio che questa volta
che ho incontrato di markham buy
[Musica]
sparando non solo da trasparente ma
sarei già quindi deve ritirare
[Musica]
no no no no niente però guarda tutto non
c'è anche la colla non ci dirà ma dovrà
stare in verde nuovamente assurda
diverse sedi tutte che fortuna meno vale
allora sembra una colla bianca a questa
casta da quella bianca che in realtà è
corrotta perché un messo un po di
colorante così almeno posso provare a
recuperare questo drive con la farina
speriamo bene ma attenta quando altri i
sindaci piano
come ricorda che mezzo come di mercato
con la farina aperte per dire ma lo più
a fazzone basso troviamo proviamo
mischiano lo vediamo un po come dio
violenta contro il city con i nostri
conti ha giocato all'ora comma 1 mag e
stato importante che siano da detto
weber
ecco qua la situazione attuale e tipo
con la super d'enza però almeno decorate
quebec lorda e può essere l'inter dentro
ok ok di uno quello rosso bianco le
pallina rosa per l'infortunato ecco qua
sono perline di tutti i colori più rota
subite
quarto e quinto solo di no le regole il
tesoro di esplodere dai francia letto
[Musica]
non riesca e tagliarlo
l'unica che può carpino totalizzato non
è il mio genio dettagliato promesse
degli italiani diputeranno legge e
magari lo capiamo quindi magari da
lasciato registro sera abbiamo qualità
il bello no dai
niente danni
[Musica]
si tocca più clienti regolativi pure il
claim marinotto impresa aperto bella
trasparente ma ti mando nell'acqua sono
[Musica]
giusto quindi torno a fare il mio dovere
eppure quindi devo ritirare si era posto
sono scambio cosa parlino con cisco
mette allora non c'è proiettato già
presero quindi rigiriamo
[Musica]
e possibile tirato
bologna monte rosa
[Musica]
le palline ho finalmente quello che
volevo prodotti
[Musica]
vediamo di tanto barraco per il cagliari
ha detto che si tiene molto piaciuto
troppa neve delle truppe non è facile
poi insieme associativo guarda a
combinare a mettere italiano è bene
magari è sempre bello con marino però
effettivamente possono scalare ma c'è
troppo ballina tutte le palline giuste
[Musica]
volta pieno con la bambina
mi capita bene tutto vero questa è la
mano perché la manovra perché 40 la bene
della root e ne in pratica dentro c'è
con lost date interrotti e schiuma da
barba è sembrato un umano con il tango e
cito forza per riprendere per quella
destra di chiamarla marmoreo un'idea di
come si starà dentro macchinette per
tante sono le dita senso sembrano
bastare i pezzi di click
quindi riesce come la schiuma da barba
si no beh troppo figo corretto ciò che
si stia bene però nello slip per passare
alcuni
chiuso perdono mica te del tuo lavoro
[Musica]
ok ecco fatto bene solo una grande
orgoglio
no ma anche a scambiarlo numero di
candidate un gesto non era bellissimo
scambio avevo detto anche da pronunciare
guardare allora internazione dei
programmi
perché siamo appena riuscito perché non
abbiamo messo
tutti
dove una folla come dobbiamo cancellare
tenere conto dell ultima ma non facciamo
carta colpisce esatto perché l'hai detto
catino che la voce è grande
devo fare
facciamo un altro box carta forbice
stando no le foto troppo lento uno
scoperto che non devi guardare che fanno
carta poi vince tasso che erano
abbastanza seriamente carta fornisce
tanto
carta borghese stato un po almeno con la
stima lunghe figo come se questo con la
schiuma da barba penso di riuscire a
salvarlo questo spray forse imprese di
operare area così farò tanti tanti suoni
see treat regolari vediamo chi vince
potrebbe recuperarlo ok vediamo si
gonfia un po perché si gonfia riusciamo
a recuperarlo park è enorme ora andiamo
a ritrovarli vediamo innanzitutto se
riusciamo ad attivarli espressi e poi
così possiamo finalmente buttare ma più
bello registrato per tutto
allora ragazzi di slime sono fronti
iniziamo un paniere il mio volo faccio
subito bella fortuna il colore è uscito
molto carino cosa per rosa ea tantissime
palline concluso è rimasto qualche pezzo
appiccicato avrebbero penati vaso
comunque vi faccio sentire i suoni
[Musica]
quindi come potete sentire fa un sacco
di bolle l'unica cosa è che la farina ha
indurito un bel po infatti vedete un po
rigido non è per elastico e poi vediamo
con il bouquet intenso che non facciamo
di essere i pochi non proprio perché non
è molto elastico vediamo
[Musica]
no sono un po sono i pochi in qualche
giorno fa ridere molto elastico però per
fortuna ho un sacco di suoni bolle
perché ci sono tante palline quindi
sentite date un voto a questo club di
effetto da 1 a 10 e suoni da 1 a 10 e
ora vediamo quello di evitare in arrivo
giovane notate come bello con tutti per
tutti colori glitter color oro e rossi
questo rosa con i cuoricini ruota
meravigliosi sentiamo subito i rumori
cominetti né di mettere dei mestieri
vista ingenti perché pochi in fantastico
effettivamente fate questo limbo king ha
ricordato come glossy che bellezza come
si estende tutto bellissimo
fermato un po incollato in questo
che con la rete contestata colorista
rosa rosa chiaro molto chiaro con
attacchi era molto chiaro meno rosa
chiaro molto chiaro ma per forse si
poteva fare poco poco di meglio che
suoni wow sono meno idioti e poi abbiamo
protection sentiamo ci sono anche le
piccole pollina bolli cinese che si un
tumore
[Musica]
allora votate votate pure per il mio da
1 a 10 data 10 ed è un bellissimo
avevano guardato stupendo poi sembra
quasi glossy per come ha fatto bene
guardino a noi ragazzi portate dei
commenti chi ha vinto mentre io l'ho
capito vitale
lasciate un bel è che questo video se
volete vedere altri fly 1 fate con i
quali magari possiamo fare
dentro un po ipes chiave giriamo una
volta emette minuto adeguato e peschiamo
il guanto col numero corrispondente
tecnici vivere se richiesti adesso
abbiamo fare appunto da santoni quanto
misterioso piccoli numeri ha fatto
quindi nostro più quel like e ora fino a
quando una telline su cui potete
cliccare per vedere i prossimi video
divertenti slide pubblicate quello che
preferite e buona fede nel siena
[Musica]